what just happened between the three of
us is the single reason that garyvee the
character exists
way too long
guys looked up to guys on dumb [ __ ]
trying to do quick cash and [ __ ]
mercedes and flick i'm here to [ __ ]
squash that because there's plenty of
people with good intent who've been
miscommunicated to take shortcuts and do
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
what was really interesting about covet
for all the challenges that it had for a
lot of us
you know it allowed us to slow down and
ponder
and for me especially
it allowed me to tap into some things
that i haven't historically talked about
and and i'm grateful for that um for
all the things i talk about around
self-awareness or gratitude or things of
that nature what's incredibly clear to
me
what's incredibly clear to me at this
point in my career is that
from a business standpoint and clearly
from a life standpoint i think we
grossly underestimate perspective
i really genuinely believe that life is
exactly as you see it i believe that
there are inherently people who are
cynical and because of that they're just
going to believe things are not good or
stacked against them and i think there
are people who are optimistic
i think there are people who are
practical and delusional and all those
things that i think many of you have
heard about but there are a couple
things that really stood out for me
um
during this last 18 months and
it really is interesting that
one of the categories i'm spending a lot
of time on right now that a lot of you
know is nft land and
and
the way i got there is what's most
interesting to me and when i thought
about what do i want to talk about
tonight what can actually bring some
value what's something that somebody can
build off of i really think it's time we
start talking about curiosity a little
bit more
so i've become incredibly passionate
about curiosity i think that
in self-reflection mode
so much of what works for me there's
many things that are part of the
equation there's many ingredients that
get me there
but curiosity is not something i saw or
really even understood as part of the
equation and i think when i think of the
collective in this room
something that is very obvious to me is
in our current society we start to
demonize curiosity pretty quickly
we get a we get a couple of years of it
as a kid but then just subconsciously
it's not some crazy agenda but
subconsciously
we start going into places that
overvalue
how it's been done
the black and white the system so much
of what i've always felt as an
entrepreneur was a vulnerability of a
school system
is not the cliche stuff that you might
see in my content but just by nature
all of us spending the majority of our
youth in a system that grades us every
90 days and we pander to a subjective
reality within that really sets us up to
eliminate our creativity and our
curiosity makes us subconsciously
conform to the short term
and inherently makes us lack patience
the other thing i'm spending a lot of
time on
is
how much we struggle with our
relationship in time and with time
you know we get sold so many things like
life is short which
you know i think all of us at this point
know depending on the context that you
look at a statement or a situation it
changes the altercation but
so many of the rules in society of when
you're supposed to have your life
figured out get married accomplish is
predicated on a world where people live
to 45 years old
it's just the reality of it so much of
what we're affected by is how our
grandparents were affected by their
parents and grandparents and those
[ __ ] were dying at 40.
of course you should have your life
figured out at 30 when you're dead at
47.
but we haven't adjusted
you know 1880 may seem a long time ago
but it's stunningly not and when life
expectancy is in the late 30s and early
40s and now we're 75 85 90 95
i just think that there's so much
confusion in the system
and
i just think that we need to have
different conversations let me give an
example a different conversation that we
need in the business world that's where
i'll keep it but it's clearly a societal
statement
is
i'm genuinely struggling why
anybody
should not be kind
i've watched in the business world for
the last 20 years
people justify being cruel
to the people that they're a manager of
or their admins
because they're stressed
i'm sorry
i scolded you you don't get it the
client
had me in a bad day we have completely
accepted
bad behavior
off of [ __ ]
[Applause]
i'm really passionate about this if
you're a leader by by nature
your job is to stop pressure at your
level
not deploy more more of it underneath
you
i think that we need to
just do better
i think that people in business are
confused
i think that
the the way that business is branded is
misbranded i think people think that if
you're kind you get walked over and i
think that is absolutely asinine
i think that a lot of people who claim
they're being walked all over are
actually just trying to manipulate
situations
and it didn't work out the way they
wanted to so they use i got walked all
over as excuse i'm kind as [ __ ] none of
you are walking over me so in the short
term and we are short-term structured
and i think that
i'm passionate at this point in my life
to really start talking about the
nuances that are very clear to me that
sustainable things
are grounded in very good virtues and
that we have to start recognizing that
soft skills will continue to dominate
and gain momentum because hard skills
are starting to be commoditized
and as technology eats up
things that people can do
with ai and many other technology
advances
robots
they'll kill us in the end we'll
probably all be gone but the robots will
win
your children will probably get killed
by robots
kidding but maybe not
but i think for all of us as we navigate
these next two three four five decades
i think it's incredibly important to
take a step back and really recognize
how much is changing
all these changes whether it's
blockchain or a mature social media
or all the other technology things are
fundamentally changing the world the
railroad system really changed [ __ ]
right airplanes really changed things
like the television really changed
things i believe that all of us are
incapable including myself to really
wrap our heads around what a mature
internet
with an emerging blockchain means to
society
and my intuition
is
that what it's definitely causing
is a very big opportunity
for
soft skills
and other things that we haven't talked
about in entrepreneurship in my brain
and in my company i call it the honey
empire
i believe you get more out of honey than
vinegar
but let there be no confusion i'm trying
to build an empire which is not a soft
word
people struggle with contradictions
i'm incredibly ambitious and tenacious
i'm incredibly fast day by day but i'm
incredibly patient i think people
struggle with patience and ambition
even though it's exactly what you see if
you study things that have been built
that are meaningful and so i think
nuances context really matters and we've
lost that we've become an incredibly
hot take headline reading society
clearly politically everybody
understands that that's the easiest
thing to read it goes beyond that
gary what's up what's up i'm freaking
out don't i am this is crazy for me guys
i mean we have garyvee in the house
[Applause]
lots of questions for gary tonight
starting with this video question from
service credit union
hi gary what is the most notable
disadvantage a micro or small business
would have in today's market more
importantly what is a key attribute a
business owner should have in overcoming
it
can i get him to play it again what's
the biggest vulnerability what is the
most notable disadvantage of a micro
small business in today's market and
what is the key attribute slash trait a
business owner should have to overcome
it and this is coming from michael
michael i think
the the biggest
vulnerability that a smaller
medium-sized business has is their
perspective that their size is their
vulnerability
the
it's it fascinates me how much people
love to think about why they're not
growing
and
no question this is the luxury of
getting so much content sent to me in
text email dms
everybody goes to
this person got more fundraising this is
a bigger company they opened a location
in my area there's a very specific
reason why david and goliath is a story
that still plays out in our society the
biggest mistake and the biggest
opportunity for a smaller business
is to be david
right the problem with small businesses
is they inherently want to be goliath
they want to be bigger but they don't
have that resource the problem with
goliath is they're slow
and audacious
it's actually very easy to build
compete with big companies today because
of the size and scale of the internet we
see it so much
if if goliath always was going to
continue to win well ibm would still be
the biggest company microsoft would have
never let google happen google would
have never let facebook happen
i think you need to when you're small
you need to lean into scaling unscalable
behaviors for small businesses and small
business owners where do they get the
confidence to grow their business and
what might be a very saturated market
what's the alternative you decided to
have a [ __ ] business
seriously though right like like
like
like the confidence comes from the
audacity of thinking that you can build
a life for yourself where you pay for
yourself and nobody else is doing it for
you you already made that decision
the alternative is go get a job and shut
down your company like you know it's i
people love capitalism and
entrepreneurship when it's working for
them right
the second it's not they don't like it i
mean i'm so tired of all my friends that
are capitalists i'm a capitalist which
means i'm willing to go to zero and if i
lose i lost
but like everyone's like such a great
entrepreneur and then somebody bigger
comes along and takes market share and
they're crying about some [ __ ] everybody
hates when the government's involved
until they need the government
stop being soft love it stop being soft
everyone myself including but it's a
very i want to stay on this it's a very
important point this is what you signed
up for
if you don't have the confidence you can
build it through
historical staying a lot you know
how many people here clap up if you've
had your own business for more than five
years
the level of admiration i have for
everybody who just clapped it's hard
your confidence should come from the
fact that you're part of a small group
of people that decided to take on the
risk to begin with
anybody who just clapped and did it for
has been doing it for five years that's
remarkable
um but don't be audacious if somebody
big comes along
they're better than you then that's what
you're saying
don't cry about it don't try to change
the rules because it's not working for
you my favorite version of it is you
were small you got bigger and hurt other
people but now somebody else came along
and is bigger than you and you're crying
about it
right you weren't crying when you were
taking other people's money
so don't cry when i'll take yours
i love it
all right this is from mark sky on
twitter my girlfriend and i are quitting
our careers to take on an ambitious 20
000 kilometer bike ride and paddle from
home in canada to a summit as a charity
adventure that lasts 18 months what is
the best way to gain
exposure
um
the best way to gain exposure is to do
the most obvious thing to everybody in
this room anybody could sit in this seat
and answer this which is to document the
entire journey yeah the question is are
you good enough
at it
everybody knows the answer you start a
vlog and you put on youtube you chop up
all the pieces of content you put on
tick tock and instagram and twitter
but are they compelling
do they know how to post that content
will they reply to all the comments
um
people's lack of patience with building
exposure is why most people don't have
any
it took me two years of wine library tv
before anybody gave a [ __ ] i did it five
days a week for two years
[Applause]
now gary in one of your podcasts uh you
said something super commendable that
you actually had a
position in your company for someone to
read the comments reply to people and
from there you guys create this
assessment as to what your content
should be can we talk a little bit about
the importance of replying to comments
and acknowledging people in social media
like in the prior session to your point
we have a we have a very prominent role
at vaynermedia called pcs
post creative strategist these
individuals jobs are to read every
comment
from every post of a brand
and then use their
psychology anthropology
skills to make observations from the
comments
by
reading the qualitative data and inform
an insight that makes the next piece of
content
the amount of people that hit me up
every day is hundreds
thousands of people who are sad that
they're not growing and then
occasionally i used to do it all the
time now i do it occasionally i will go
look at their account 90 of those people
don't even reply to the 15 people that
leave a comment if you're in this
audience and you're sad that your
profile is not growing on the business
side or the personal side and you are
not replying to every comment you get
from the content you are putting out
you are audacious
thank you
i love this next question from michael
on twitter he asks what are the key
principles to happiness and success in
life
um
i believe it's simplicity
i really do i think
i think for the people that know me in
my life
i'm really simple you know i really
enjoy my career i love this like i'm you
couldn't even imagine
how humbled i am by people's interest
and what i talk about
but
i think the key to happiness
is being content while being ambitious
and i think being content comes from
gratitude i'm so grateful for what i
have and i've always been that way that
all this special stuff that has been
happening
doesn't mean enough to me this is not
where my self-worth comes in
the garyvee crap and the collapse and
the follower like it's incredible
but
it's not what i aspire
to it's not how i see my value
and i think
the only way to be happy is to have a
quiet mind and i think a quiet mind
comes from
a balance of very deep humility and true
perspective of understanding that you
like you just genuinely understand that
you don't mean [ __ ] in the scheme of
things but you aspire in your behavior
to mean something and i think it's a
very interesting balance and i think
it works incredibly well i just wish
people
people are just impossibly addicted to
outside affirmation
to acceptance
and
i wish people lived in their own cocoon
and just
did the things that made them happy so
many people
would aspire to make so much less money
if they didn't care about what other
people think and would be dramatically
happier
dramatically happier and i wish that on
society now what do you do when yeah
it's a good one
they're all good ones
it's it's a tough conversation because
in the business world so many people
think that scoring is based on how big
your net worth is or how much money you
make and it's it's really unfortunate
because i think troop red
entrepreneurship
almost doesn't give a [ __ ] about all the
collateral that comes along with it it's
art you just love doing it
and
we've got to find our balance much like
the chat i had up front
as i spend the next half decade refining
what i talked to you about up there and
what i'm talking about right now is we
have to change
the definition of success
we have to it cannot be the flex we
cannot put
expensive watches and cars and bank
accounts on a pedestal we we must get
away from that but that doesn't mean we
demonize it either
we have to make it about the process of
the game
we've got to find we've got to find our
way because right now we're over here
we've got to find this
now gary tell me when when life hits
when the storm of life hits because
we've all been there no matter who you
are how do you remain in that state and
that space of gratitude and balance
very easily when your entire life is
only predicated on the health and
well-being of a small group of people
you love more than breathing
nothing scares you
i love it
i mean
the first couple months of cove at
vayner was a very weird spot i don't
build it for profit so we didn't have
profit
you know i built it for growth we were
very weird in the u.s the way they
subsidized businesses we were in the
middle we weren't small enough and we
weren't big enough so we got nothing
all of our clients are humongous
and all of them right away said we're
going to slow down the way we pay you
you know it was a very big challenge and
i just remember
having the greatest moment with myself
when it was super scary week one
saying oh my god everything i've been
telling them is true if this company
goes out of business
i'll be beyond okay
i love that yeah i have a question
because what you said prior to what you
just said really hit home for me because
in my previous role in my previous job i
actually attached my worth and my
identity to
income my job my work my schedule social
media because i worked so hard to get it
i fell in kind of that loophole then
life hit me with a very big wake-up call
and i was stuck with this super
uncomfortable feeling of
my internal changing and if i didn't
change my external it just wasn't
working and i became a very unhappy
person so just in case there's anyone in
the crowd and in the fans in the
audience anyone listening online who can
relate what would be your advice to them
to have that courage to start redefining
success in their life
that they can
you know like everybody's so obsessed on
what they've done and said
like the greatest gift in the world is
the ability to be comfortable in
changing your mind
i love it
actually i have a very different
thing to say right now we need to start
hanging out with 90 year olds more
i mean this
you wanna you wanna you wanna do
something that will bring you an
incredible amount of value but also
bring someone else an incredible amount
of value
go
donate your time to a retirement home
for one week you will learn a lesson
real fast
that 99 of the stuff that all of you are
right now thinking about means jack [ __ ]
this is a game of perspective
i don't understand how we don't
understand that
we
you must
shift perspective into simplicity which
then makes the ability to do what we all
do so much more palpable because there's
no weight on it because it doesn't
matter as much which then inherently
makes it more enjoyable
of course you're going to burn out
if your entire self-worth is and how
good your business is doing
of course you're going to burn out
a funny thing happens you don't burn out
from games when you make your career a
game
things change very quickly i love that
i'm going to start the clap on that one
all right next we have a video question
from a facebook winner matt hoover
it's matt with tubertowing here in
edmonton uh absolutely love what you do
the focus big time on the humility
aspect we're five years stronger on 20
to 30 year-over-year we got 20 albertans
working with us and just just rocking it
our question for you is how do we get
from the small business to the
medium-sized business we got managers
and we're helping them succeed but how
do we let go how do we grow that to the
next level
you know
what's tough about video questions is
you want to ask the you know there's the
next question there it's like you know
again
i talk about these thematics a lot and i
will repeat them to my death
the best way to go from a small business
to a medium business
is by deploying patients and doing what
you did
to get to become a small business of
course there's strategies i've been very
consistent about this for 15 years i put
out a very simple message that has been
uncomfortably historically true if you
understand where the customer's
attention is and you know how to make
pictures videos and written words for
those platforms you will grow
for that gentleman's business if he got
great at linkedin ads his top line
revenue would grow
the question is how is he judging
himself by the way what is even a small
or medium business like what are the
rules of all this [ __ ] it's like is 5
million small is 50 million medium like
what is this [ __ ]
i'm sure there's some answer to it if
you google it but everybody's answer is
different
right like what like it's these constant
games of making these things for us you
know what that is that's [ __ ] the
90-day school great [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you trying to do for
tomorrow what is that he's going to make
his own subjective call if he's a medium
business or a small business
we're playing dumb [ __ ] games out
here oh my gosh
i love it i love it
gary you speak a lot what's a
medium-sized business uh honest to god
i'm with you who effing knows
but really is it 50
somebody what's a medium-sized business
no no revenue not people you
five million bucks somebody just said
that's a medium-sized business that's
small as [ __ ] to me
that's a [ __ ] business perspective
but this is important to understand
i'm not right i'm not cool
i'm not special it just doesn't work for
my brain
for somebody else a million's insane
that's insane do you know how hard it is
to build a million dollar business
and oh by the way
what about the fact that you change over
time what about 23 a 5 million dollar
business is a medium-sized business but
then you're 36 and it's not or it goes
down like we just we play in these
semantics
that don't mean anything except make us
anxious
you speak to uh patients a lot and i'm
very curious to hear this answer because
i am not patient at all and i'm one of
these people where i have this grand
idea and if there isn't this outcome
that i'm looking for within the week i
immediately think that i'm failing and
i'm doing a miserable job and no one
cares so if there's anyone out there
who's like me what advice would you give
them in being patient with their
business do you remember in sixth grade
when you had a zit and you were scared
[ __ ] used to go to school
no but everybody else had zits too
yeah that's my answer to that question i
love that
this
this is where humility is a [ __ ]
superpower you may see bravado on stage
my
my happiness is grounded in humility
you know what humidity humility looks
like in this scenario
why
if you don't think you're important it's
almost like your results don't matter
who are you disappointing yourself those
are voices that were put inside of you
by somebody else
but what if you're a perfectionist like
what if you expect 12 out of 10 if
you're a perfectionist you're insecure
well that's a good hit me right between
the eyes without one
well if you're getting a shitload of
views and a lot of not a lot of
conversions it doesn't sound like it's a
platform
issue it sounds like your offering isn't
good
no no it's not that by the way by the
way this is why business is so funny to
me that's a good thing that wasn't a bad
thing that wasn't a razz that's a okay
cause because listen to how the question
was asked i'm not on the right platform
you're getting plenty of attention
you're not converting which means you
have to understand that what you're
offering isn't landing and this is where
curiosity and humility to take a step
back and say how do i tweak this
right because you might be an inch away
brother you might literally have to drop
the price by 10 bucks add a day change a
word and everything flows but what
people often do is they go to the front
to fix when the back is the issue it's
never this everyone here is obsessed
with the sink it's the [ __ ] well
you know what's so crazy now i'm gonna
get up
listen what what you just did about i
see his true intent but when you were
squirming with everything i said
no in a good way in a good way i know
it's the what just happened between the
three of us is the single reason that
garyvee the character exists
way too long
guys looked up to guys on dumb [ __ ]
trying to do quick cash and [ __ ]
mercedes and like i'm here to [ __ ]
squash that because there's plenty of
people with good intent who've been
miscommunicated to to take shortcuts and
do [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay let's keep going okay
all right this is a tweet from rob how
does one balance family life two small
businesses and a full-time job
by not judging themselves i love that
can we go deeper into that how does that
look easy
there is no such thing as work-life
balance every family is different
there you know there is no such thing
called balance you're the judge in the
jury just like a medium-sized business
or a small business
we do these things to make ourselves
upset we have to stop how do you balance
it by trying
[Applause]
you try
you try to go to the recital you try to
go to the parent-teacher conference you
try to run your business you try
and if you try your hardest and can't do
it you should not judge yourself what is
can't yeah
what's can't do it what does that even
[ __ ] mean you missed a baseball game
come on
the kids can have you miss a [ __ ]
baseball game
you you're everything it's true
it's true every single person here
has 9 700 things they can think of that
their parents [ __ ] up and they still
love them
and oh by the way
forgot 8 trillion things their parents
did that was [ __ ] up
we are in some crazy [ __ ]
dynamic of like over analyzing
everything so [ __ ] much with a layer
of cynicism that is making everybody go
[ __ ] crazy
if you are a good person and you're
trying truly trying and not trying to
hurt anybody you're [ __ ] phenomenal
enough
how do we how do we eliminate that
outside noise sometimes you know you not
[ __ ] caring about other people's
opinions once and for all high school
high school is [ __ ] over stop playing
in it
it's over you left
you're not in [ __ ] high school you
are i know but everybody else
stop
it's over what
what
who your mom tell your mom to go [ __ ]
herself she [ __ ] up too
what you're spelling what who what
[ __ ] just living for other people's
judgment everybody else sucks [ __ ] too
now now if you're gonna tell your mom
that how do you have the courage to have
that kind of conversation with her
because you don't say it the way i'm
saying it you say it a different way you
say mom i appreciate your opinion of how
i'm being a father how about the time
you did this that shuts them up real
fast
i love it i love it like i just don't
understand
how people are so deeply into this
affirmation culture keeping up with the
joneses
it's just really a problem and it's
getting worse by the second and
newsletter it's not social media's fault
it's your fault
this lack of accountability is [ __ ]
disgusting
we have to go deeper and we have to be
more optimistic and positive
we have to become more optimistic and
positive you know why you get to decide
life just so you know news alert you're
deciding what life actually is
it is your subjective call
and if you are if you're like well gary
[ __ ] you i grew up in a family that was
very pessimistic and this is what it is
well then what do you want then go to
therapy
right like do something
fight for it fight to be happy
listen to positive [ __ ]
that's a funny game
miraculous thing happens when you cut
out your most pessimistic friend you
become more optimistic
and let me tell you about complaining
the only people that are listening to
your complaining are people that
extremely love you but are enablers
or your other loser friends and you're
just complaining to each other
how about those people who um because
i'm sometimes like this i have high
anxiety in certain moments and i create
this narrative this storyline in my head
where i'm like this person's judging me
because of this or this this person's
mad at me because he didn't look at me
today and didn't say hello and i said
hello to him how do you escape that
mental block because sometimes that's
why i make it pretend that you're gonna
die tomorrow actually i love that i'm
being serious i'm giving you my answer
how the [ __ ] am i gonna care about
johnny thinking that i'm not good
looking today if i'm gonna die tomorrow
you think i'm gonna care about that
we don't have perspective
all of a sudden miraculously people
stopped worrying about a lot of things
when coveted hit
that was
funny changed
we just
care about dumb [ __ ] because the world
is too good
how about that one
how about that one my friends
we've decided it's so bad because it's
so good
look at the data
what can i tell you
too much prosperity
this is where again humility comes in
so much of this good [ __ ] for me
it's all so many entrepreneurs struggle
with the word luck i do
i worked so hard since i was 14 years
old i struggle with it
but i'm incredibly lucky i was born in a
communist country and was in the right
time in the right place my grandfathers
both spent years in jail for being
entrepreneurs in russia and i get
clapped for in edmonton
right
you know so so
so
i i lived in a studio apartment the size
of this [ __ ] stage with [ __ ]
multiple family members so i i have
perspective i'm grateful for everything
i have we lack gratitude you understand
that right
you lack gratitude there are almost two
billion people on earth that don't have
access to clean water
are you a [ __ ] [ __ ]
think about what i just said
there are over a billion people on earth
that don't have access to clean water
and you're complaining that your
instagram's not growing [ __ ] you
okay this next photo can i can we stay
on this one i'd love to i'd love are we
good guys
i'd love to you want to take anxiety out
of the system you want to be happier
look at the world and be grateful for
what you have everybody's so interested
in paying attention to people that have
more than them they don't recognize that
there's way more people that have less
than them
so so gary what do you do to stay
grounded to stay in the space of
gratitude is there are there
affirmations that you say do you
meditate do you spend time with your
family what is your source of that that
gratitude
my source is that i was extremely
fortunate with
the luck of the dna game and outrageous
levels of remarkable parenting by my mom
that's me
that's me
that's
that's why i stand up here today not
thinking anything of me all this things
that i'm spewing i'm just a vehicle
passing through what my mom gave to me
and i'm sure she got you know like i
don't think there's anything special
about me i know what i'm saying is
special and important i know a lot of
other people know it to be true
i have so much judgment on me in the
world because i am obsessed with talking
about positive things in a world where
anger and darkness is loud and happiness
is quiet
what you're seeing on the mainstream
media and social media is the loud dark
minority
the problem is
the quiet happy majority is quiet
[Applause]
if you're happy do me a favor share it
and not flex it
don't show them you're happy with your
porsche
rick
talk about real [ __ ] this is real talk
here you uh
you're a son of immigrant parents i'm a
daughter of immigrant parents my
beautiful mom is here today her and my
dad escaped communist poland back in the
80s created this unbelievable life here
in canada
and i remember listening to you on a
podcast i think maybe the moment where i
truly fell in love with garyvee and you
said your greatest gift was being the
son of immigrant parents 100 and
adversity is the foundation of success
[Music]
this macro prosperity
is the foundation of anxiety
you don't worry about everything we talk
about in society when you don't have
food
gary did you ever have anxiety did you
ever put these pressures on yourself
when you started first creating content
how did you get if you ever were in this
space of doubt and fear and insecurity
how did you get out of that bubble
if you that the most insecure place i've
ever been in was the fear of
confrontation
which blows people's mind because on st
on stage in public persona it's candor
is my strength
but in real life
i hated candor because my father was
very aggressive with candor but very
negative
and i wasn't able to separate the
vehicle he was deploying the candor in
from the value of candor so
for 25 years of my career i was anxious
every time i decided somebody had to get
fired it completely put me into spirals
i would avoid it it was always sloppy
it only
to a t every person that's ever been
close to me in business that works for
me or worked for me that doesn't love me
is based on one thing my inability to be
cancerous and it's been a very big shift
for me in the last three four years the
new book is called 12 and a half it's
about 13 attributes
but i call it 12 and a half because i'm
only halfway through my journey on kind
candor and i needed to create the word
kind in front of candor to even begin to
deploy candor and it has led to an
incredible amount of unhappiness in my
life and career was my inability to be
candice which is wild because my content
is incredibly candice because i'm not
talking to anybody
i'm talking to everybody
but when it's steve or sally or johnny
or nicole or karen it was very hard for
me and so
now i do it
would you change
would you change anything about your
journey or your process
even the negative moments the
life-changing moments the things that
you didn't love
if you're here right now and you could
of course not
of course not it
would be crazy i love that i agree
it's all about the process the the
number one people looking backwards
backwards dwelling it's over i don't
know if you guys heard we have not
invented time machines yet
you're not going back anyway people sit
and dwell
and they make these subjective calls
this keeps going back to the theme of
tonight they make subjective calls that
that's where their life got ruined
and they decide that that's where their
life got ruined for 47 years they think
about it
it's no i think i'm incredibly grateful
and i always do a fun game with myself
which is maybe something on paper would
have been something great but maybe that
would have led me to going over here and
that's where i would have gotten hit by
a bus you know like i believe in that
i'm very
i'm very imaginative of it could be
worse it could be worse it's just
completely one big game of gratitude and
i want i i come and do this because i'm
passionate about one person in this
audience emailing me in nine years
saying i was in edmonton in 2021 and i
wasn't grateful you're right i was
spoiled i was entitled i was delusional
and i practiced it and it changed my
life i believe in that because i'm on
the receiving end of that now 15 years
later i like it it feels good it makes
me feel nice it's a better feeling
it's when you're when you're full when
you're full
when you're good
you have nowhere to go but trying to
make it good for everybody else which is
why i know
that i have to deploy sympathy and
empathy for everyone who's mean to me
because they're not good they're hurt so
they're trying to drag me down to be
hurt with them people struggle with
negative comments i'm gonna save you i'm
gonna make you get real comfortable with
negative comments on social media and in
life
they're hurt
don't feel bad for you feel bad for them
they're showing you their hand they're
upset they're hurt
you're welcome my man
all right everyone please give it up for
mr garyvee himself
thank you so much really
thank you
thank you so much
i love you edmonton
thank you thank you thank you so much
thank you ah thank you you're great
thank you so much
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight this is the time to
subscribe i hope you consider it and i
hope i see you soon